It's an expensive place to be.
Let me tell you my income's down 30%, you know,
they're just things I can't do because I'm associated with saying something too
nice about it.
That's when I first met you, you weren't even a Trump supporter at the time,
you were just sort of talking about the techniques he was using.
And just because of that, everyone said, Oh,
Scott Adams is mad guy he's far right. All of that nonsense,
not that you were supporting some of his policies necessarily,
but you were just saying, this is how he is doing these things.
This is how he is gaining a following and getting his message out. Right.
Um, um, I identify as left of Bernie. So I still do now.
I still do because socially, uh, you know, I could give you some examples,
but socially I do. But what I,
what I eventually saw in Trump is they had a,
a toolkit that I thought could just do stuff.
Other people wouldn't do take on China. That's the toolkit you want,
uh, be the best cheerleader for the economy.
Literally get our psychology work in the right direction. Hey,
everything's good. Everything's good. Why don't you invest? Okay.
That's the psychology of the economy.
I thought nobody's going to do that as well as him. Um, and likewise,
North Korea, I thought who could, who could have a meeting? Well,
before it happened, I already written about it. I said,
who could have the meeting with Kim Jong-un and just turn this personal,
maybe find a way in president Trump.
So I'm a supporter in terms of his toolkit, but you know,
it doesn't mean I agree with everything he does.
Yeah. That's a hard place to be in though. Right?
Because people don't really care for that second part of that sentence.
It's an expensive place to be. Let me tell you, because my income's down 30%,
you know,
they're just things I can't do because I'm associated with saying something too
nice about his skill.
You talk about that a little bit more.
Like what kind of business things have dried up or, or even personal friends,
or I don't want to say specifically or where you live,
but you do live in California. I mean,
you live in a place that is maybe not so hospitable to some of these ideas.
Let's just say, uh,
there was a rebuilding period where I had to make new friends, a lot of them,
you know.
What phase of that building process are you in right now?
You know, I'm living a very good life with my girlfriend, Christina,
we're quite happy with the way things are. So I don't have a complaint there.
It's just an observation that is socially.
It became very difficult to have the same friends.
What was that like?
Cause I think everyone watching this has been through that to some degree. My,
my book is, is about that.
It's about what happens as you start sort of coming out of the political closet
that you sort of get thrown under the bus by people that you thought were your
friends, next thing you know, there's this whole other crew that's welcoming.
You it's. I mean, it really is sort of a flip on everything, you know? Yeah.
Only, only my most, uh,
let's say honest friends were willing to say it to my face and that only
happened a few times,
but mostly I just noticed that my Facebook feed started to getting,
it was getting emptier and emptier. I'd be like, huh,
really only one picture was all this week by all, everybody I know that's weird.
And then you see that they've unfriended you and then you check their feeds and
you see what their political leaning is. You put two plus two together.
Then here we are. Yeah.
How does your background in persuasion and magic and the
cartoon and everything sort of fit your, your general demeanor?
I said to you right before we started that, you're one of the few people that I,
that I now know that when I see them on Twitter, I don't like them less.
There are so many people that I know that,
and we all are not necessarily our best selves on,
on Twitter and online in general. But I see so many people that like,
I kind of respect or I know. And um,
and then I look at their Twitter and I'm like, Ooh, what, what is going on here?
And I'm sure there's people that say that about me too,
but you seem like you're pretty like pretty much the same in both worlds.
Fair. There were a lot of people look at my Twitter and say,
you're the worst person in the world I used to like your comic,
but now I can never laugh again. Just in general. I can never laugh again.
Taking away their ability, not just to laugh at you, but the whole thing.
Have you noticed that the humor has just completely changed
as has been said? You can't make a movie, a funny movie, a funny TV show.
In fact,
if you watch like an old family guy rerun the whole time I'm sitting there
thinking you couldn't make that.
Couldn't do that. One could do that. One could do that one.
But humor has become a reality and politics and it's very
entertaining. And thankfully we have the funniest president we've ever had.
So as a satirist though, what do you make of the comedy side of this?
Cause you know, it's somebody like Seth McFarland who created family guy,
you know, they've said, I don't know that they're going through with it,
but I remember a few months back,
they had said this thing where they're not going to do any more gay jokes.
And it's like, well, the show did, you know,
25 years of gay jokes and now gays are equal.
So this might be the time to make a joke. So you can, you know,
further integrate people into society. That's what Don Rickles did. Right.
It brought us all together. Um, or, or the Simpsons, you know,
they were going to take out our poo for a while. And then Hank Azaria,
the greatest voiceover actor of all time had to apologize for doing an Indian
accent. What do you make of the, not just the content, but the people behind it,
you know, they'd been infected.
I'm generally okay.
With the concept that society moves forward and things that we used to laugh
at, we didn't realize were cruel. And then maybe you grow up and say, Oh,
that was really meaner than it needed to be. What was it?
Wasn't really trying to do that. Uh, and so I'm okay with society evolving,
but the trouble is, it evolved away.
All the things that were the normal joke materials.
Now it didn't affect me with Dilbert because when you're in a family newspaper,
there's, you know, there's a cap on what you can do.
So I was always well in the family friendly version and talking about the
workplace. So it didn't affect me much,
but it certainly changed the landscape of humor probably forever. Yeah.
Do you feel freer because I think you said to me last time you were here that
you you've got some F-you money so that you can kind of be free enough to do
what you want.
Yeah. I mean, I didn't think it would be expensive as it was. Maybe,
maybe I would have thought it through, but no, it won't change my lifestyle.
And, uh,
I did recognize that I was in this unique position where I had something to
say that in my opinion was not biased. You know, it was just, Hey,
this is what I'm seeing. There's a little good. And there's a little bad here.
So I thought it was a unique niche, niche niche.
I'll go with either one. Well, I'll take either one. I.
Shouldn't say words. I never said that out loud. I.
Would've said niche personally, but I would accept niche.
Uh, as I look at your lovely decorations here,
I think that you were probably right.
I'm better suited to figure out the critic, the correct pronunciation,
just like it fits somehow. I dunno. What do you make? Or just sort of how,
as a guy that, you know, you sort of came out of newspapers,
as you said that now you use all of this stuff in a different way. You know,
you sit in the morning, do you do it every morning? You do it pretty,
pretty much every morning, right? You get on Twitter.
What do you have your phone just like locked on something and you make yourself
some coffee and you just kind of talk to the world that that's a big transition
from, you know,
putting a cartoon in the paper and letting it be okay versus this fully a
directive thing.
Yeah. The difference is it's all. Yes.
I do coffee with Scott Adams on the Periscope app every day. And then,
then it moves over to YouTube at about an hour later on replay.
But I started doing it cause I was just interested in the election
and there were people to talk to and I had more to say,
and I didn't feel like writing it all down all the time.
Cause every day there'd be three new things to talk about.
And then it just grew. I wasn't, I didn't really have any expectation, no plan.
Wasn't planning to even monetize it. Uh, it just grew into a thing.
And now if I miss a day because I do it on a weekend and Stu holidays,
cause people are so addicted to having the simultaneous sip as I call it.
So I do a toast of coffee with the public and that they
miss it. And so now it's sort of labor of love. Um, I would really,
really miss it like this morning, my wifi wasn't working so well.
And I was like, ah, I don't know if I could do it,
but I got my hotspot working and then it made me happy. Right? Like most,
most awarded at it from here.
We wouldn't let you in rather than great most work. Doesn't make you happy.
You know, you might like your job, but it doesn't make you happy.
Whereas doing the Periscopes, it's just a joy every day.
Yeah. I actually did it one morning.
I did coffee with Dave and I did fully credit. You rip the coffee idea.
No one was talking with coffee before you,
but I did think that there was something nice about just starting the day.
Just sort of unloading a couple of thoughts, just, just that in and of itself.
I thought it was kind of refreshing.
Yeah. And it has the, uh,
unintended consequence that I often frame things before people wake up.
So if there's something that happens, say in the afternoon,
the pundits and people haven't had much time to deal with it.
And sometimes I'm the first person they hear saying, well,
the way to look at this is this is important. And this isn't,
and then somewhat accidentally I became influential.
Do you think that's sort of your primary skill,
like a sort of framing of the craziness and what we're obviously going to get to
the book in a little bit,
but I think that's sort of what you're doing is you're helping people frame
through just like this endless onslaught of information.
So I often say I have one superpower,
so I've got one super power and then a bunch of like supporting talents that
I've tried to piece together over time, the super power is simplification.
Uh, I'm just a really good simplifier,
which is what makes one a cartoonist cartoon is by its definition.
The simplest thing you can put in this little panel. So if you can simplify,
you can frame because it's taking down all the noise,
focusing on the thing that mattered.
So I naturally have that skill as a simplifier.
Yeah.
It's kind of funny because that's almost the reverse of what everyone else is
doing. And this sort of is what the book is about.
Like everyone else is pretending they know everything about everything all day
long, you know,
people who can't tie their shoes can tell you about climate change and you know,
the rest of it. So it's like,
you're sort of doing the reverse of what seemingly most of the blue check a
Twitterati.
You, you should ignore anybody who has a sense of complete certainty about a
complicated issue, you know, unless they're a surgeon and it's their domain.
But if it's just a guy on Twitter talking about climate change or the,
I don't know, trade with China, I don't know.
How do you figure out who you kind of can listen to or make some sense out of or
something like that?
I just helped a little, everybody.
I find the only way to look at all the windows is you've got to like figure out
what everybody's saying.
And then maybe you've got a little bit of a ability to determine which one
is more sensitive.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.